hello
so uh our next speaker is marvel new
year and murphy is a developer advocate
attacking face working on developing
tools and building content around them
to democratize machine learning for
everyone and she'll explain to us how to
showcase our model demos with spaces so
i'm very exciting to learn more about
those
that's awesome
just a question for you um the the one
that i should share is move a talk or
move a space demo yeah navi talk first
and then nervous plays demos second
great
just adding this now
moment of truth are we still alive yeah
you soon for the questions
hello everyone and welcome to the
hugging face course event
i'm marve and in this talk i'll be
talking about spaces
i was a machine learning engineer
building information extraction tools
and chat bots
currently i'm working as a developer
advocate at hugging face and a graduate
student working on nlp
at hugging phase we provide you data
sets and models you need to build your
machine learning applications those are
the hub
transformers and data sets
i come from a data science pad rather
than a developer path and one thing i
found painful was building the most of
the models i created and deploying them
if you are just like me we've got you
covered with our new feature called
spaces
for instance i have this story generator
app which consists of three models
sequentially added together
i have one model that is from french to
english
one english story generator and another
model from english to french
i written this up with only few lines of
code and deployed it in minutes and i
will show you how to do that
and no i didn't write any javascript
code or didn't build my api with flask
i used gradual for this and deployed it
on spaces
we support both streamlit and graduate
sdks
basically i define my interface in
gradio
i pass the example inputs to help the
end user
define title and description to my demo
pass three models as series added
together i defined my input component
which is a text box and launched it
uploading this piece of code to spaces
will be enough for me to serve it and
showcase my projects to the stakeholders
in hugging phase you can work with the
stakeholders of your project in hugging
face organizations
and share your spaces internally
build your demos and showcase your
models to the stakeholders or clients
personally i find easy to showcase my
portfolio through hugging face spaces
they are hosted on your profile
you might say it's cool but which sdk
should i use
we recommend you to give a try to both
our two sense is
with gradio you can build easy to use
simple interfaces by specifying your
model
inputs and outputs
meanwhile streamlit provides more
flexibility with the community
components
there are many cool spaces out there for
instance this anime gown space draws you
as an anime character this is built with
gradio
another cool space lets you chat with
gandalf this one is built with gradua as
well
you simply need to go to hub on top
right corner click your icon and create
a new space
name your space pick the sdk you want to
use and create your space
directly drag and drop your app.pi file
or use git lfs to push your application
to space
and you will have your app in minutes
if you need extra help with sdks and
spaces i've written two blog posts for
both of the sdks to help you get started
thanks a lot for listening and enjoy the
event
now just quickly have a look at a
hands-on demo from merve with a space
and then we'll dive into a q a
thanks
this is one of my favorite projects and
it has generative models
that you can write to it
so
let's write my name is marve and i like
to
[Music]
this is going to complete my text and i
have replicated with streamlid and
transformers
it takes couple of parameters that i
will explain shortly
so let's go there
so this is my space and i have
replicated right with transformers
uh it takes maximum length uh
temperature and this is a parameter that
decides the
conservativeness and how random your
outputs are going to be
these are sampling parameters
let's do this
so i have written hi i'm marv and i like
to play games let's say my name is marv
and i like to
i like to play guitar i am student at
university of texas at austin okay
so how i did it
good question i'm going to show you how
did i do that shortly
so my streamlined application actually
consists of only an app.pi file
requirements file and the readme
so
so i have written an inference code
i have written the same thing using only
pipeline which was a very short code but
i wanted to show you this one
in particular
so in streamlit if you would like to
optimize some processes that take a lot
of time you can do
sd.cache
it will load your model in a faster way
and i have written this inference code
which takes a couple of parameters
these parameters will come from the ui
here
and i'm going to tell you how to do that
shortly
so this is the title
which is here it's like a header
and
this is sd.write you write some text
and you can take your parameters here
so if you do st sidebar
this is going to take your slider to the
sidebar if not
it will be here but i want it to be here
so i have taken it to the sidebar
i have temperature i have top k and top
p if you have an integer
input use number input if you have a
continuous input use slider
and i have my text area which i will
input the text in
this is the default value so it's see
how a neural network autocompletes your
text so it was here previously and i
have taken it to here
this was the default value
and i do inference
and i just
output
the
result of the inference
and i just write it there so it is
it is here
next i'm going to show you a gradual
application
so i have made another application which
is story generation with gpt2
i'm going to show you how to do that but
let's run it for a second
so i use it to generate dungeons and
dragons
stories
i have entered adventures approached by
a mysterious stranger in the tavern for
a new quest
and it has generated me a nice beautiful
probably scandinavian related
story
and i'm going to show you how i did that
so
this is my app.pi file i only have this
and nothing else by the way
i have given description
which is this and the title
and an example
to give a hint to the user so that they
know
what they are supposed to input
so
examples are given as a list
uh i am going to give
the
uh model name
uh make sure to put a hugging face
uh slash to indicate that this is a
hugging face model this is the model
name
i have past title and description and i
just launched it and i have this
beautiful
interface
now i'm going to show you something even
more interesting which is gradua series
so this is
a
french story generator but i have used
the same model
so i have an example again i'm going to
submit this and i will probably not
understand uh what is
what does it output
but
still this is probably something valid
so let me show you how i did that
so i'm going to go to my app.pi file
so
in graduate there is something called
series
it adds your models
sequentially
so i have three models here
one is from french to english
another one is story generator and this
one is from english to french
so
what i'm basically doing is that
my first input
is inferred inside this
from french to english model
here
and
my second input
which is the output of the first input
is going to be inferred in this story
generator and my uh
the output of this story generator will
be inferred here
so in the end i'm going to autocomplete
this input
so in the end i have a nice
french story generator
which is this beautiful application done
with graduate with only
few lines of code
so last application i will show you is a
streamlined exploratory data analysis
hosted in hugging face spaces
so i have this poetry data set
which consists of various poetries
authors
uh the name
age and the type
i have uh i have done a couple of data
visualization on this data set
some of them consist of streamlets
components which are very good
interactive nicely done
other ones are matplotlib and seaborn
so let's get started
the good thing about this component is
that uh
you can see the content of a cell
you can order
uh
by columns
which is very good
i have done a couple of visualizations
in matplotlib i'm going to show you
uh
i have
visualized the number of
poems for the each author and this is
done in seabourn
i have shown the distribution
of poem types according to ages and
authors
this is also done in matplotlib
i have
i have done a word cloud of modern poems
and renaissance poems
and i have standardized the content of
the data set
by getting rid of special characters and
lowercasing them
so i'm writing my explanations and
headers using extremely components right
subheader
so if you would like to use seaborn and
matplotlib you can use st.piplot
to print your matte platleband seaborne
plots
that's what i did with the matte
plataban seabourn platz in this
in this application
so to get the distributions i have done
a couple of encoding and i plot it
and i have shown it with streamlet
pipelot as well
so for the word cloud i got the
renaissance poems and the modern poems
i have passed them to the word cloud to
prompt them
so lastly i have this bar charts that
prompts most appearing words including
stop words i have
the most appearing 50 words
this was the bar chart i have just shown
you
the interactive one
so
this is the end of the demo enjoy the
rest of the event
welcome back
hi again
so thanks a lot for all this uh token
for this demo
thank you so much for hosting me
so uh my uh first question is that you
showed uh an example of a live demo of a
model and another example where you did
some data visualization of a data set
and what are our application of spaces
uh that are common or that you could
think of
um can you rephrase the question again
i was saying like you you should an
example of uh using a model
and then you also showed an example of
like doing a data set visualization both
using species and i was wondering are
there like other amazing application of
spaces
that are common
like those two or is this done pretty
much for the two things you showed us
ah
i have to think about it i i don't know
uh there is probably like there are so
many good applications like there is
this one application called pipeline
visualizer by omar
uh he has visualized the
visualize the spacey pipelines uh it is
really good
um
what else i i want to create this um
this
data visualization
metric tool sort of using streamlined on
hacking face like i'm on it at the
moment so hopefully it will be done
but people are also like showing their
tools uh demoing them
which is awesome so i think you will
probably get to do that as well
nice very nice and another question was
like for the for the model
demonstrations uh what kind of hardware
does the space run is on is it like just
a cpu or do we have access to gpus using
spaces
we do have access to gpus but i don't
think that all of the spaces are
actually getting them it's
it's a complicated answer actually but
most of them have cpus
yeah that makes sense
and um let me check so
it's a forum
[Music]
did you have any questions serious on
your end
yeah i was wondering like um
you know if we if we want to build
something in extreme little radio what
do you see is like the main
sort of benefits or trade-offs between
them because they're kind of quite
different philosophically
yeah i just feel like um
graduate is incredibly easy
machine learning demo you know like you
can build your machine learning model
demos in like minutes because it also
has built-in uh components uh for s4
streamlit it has this basis and it
covers you from exploratory data
analysis to the end
uh but the problem is if you want to
if you want to um if you want to use
something additional like spacey
components or you know video components
you you need additional dependencies for
them
so i would go with um if if i were to
demo some data visualizations and stuff
i would definitely go with stream it
also provides a lot of flexibility
but if i want to wrap up a
very easy
demo of my machine learning model i
would use gradio we we recommend both of
them and both of them are awesome it's
just there are some trade-offs
in both of them
cool and exactly
another question might be that um
when i'm building say a project in the
in the course event in the next couple
of days
um most people who say are using
transformers they're pretty familiar
with the pipeline function which wraps
all of the post-processing and
pre-processing
um but i think i saw in in one of your
demos that you were
actually kind of calling the back end i
think you were you were using something
um maybe on the inference api and i was
just wondering if you could kind of
explain about that and why would i do
that instead of just using a pipeline
function
to be honest i just saw more flexibility
by calling from pretrained then colin
pipeline or inference api i just wanted
the model to be cached and
just
ready to use and also when you do
streamlit cache i think it's cached in
container so it's like it it loads
really
it it loads really um fast but you can
also use pipeline it's it's very um
it's very easy to write your inferences
with pipeline and also inference api i
totally recommend them i have bought by
the way like i have done both but for
this one
i just wanted to show more code that's
why i actually picked the uh one that i
have written with pro from
pre-trained yeah i think one thing that
i found is um if you have a lot of
models like for example right now i'm
building a streamlit
application which has like 10 like
different models and this is maybe a
case where the inference api is really
useful because you can't load in the
yeah of course of the container
like
people are demoing their models in
streamlit by putting a drop down and in
that drop down there are like multiple
models like for right with transformers
if i were going to
uh do with you know gpt to you know
excel net and other generative models i
would definitely use inference api but
for this one i only had gpt2 that's why
i also picked it but i i i have written
this for my blog post actually and i
have explained all of the code there
so that's why i actually wanted to demo
that then that was my reason for that
particular one
cool
um maybe one last question is asking
everyone this uh what do you do at
hugging face so what what is a developer
advocate at hugging face and maybe you
can just explain a little bit like um
you know that it's not the standard kind
of job yeah
um to be honest before i landed in
hugging face i was a huge fan of hugging
face and everyone in here
and
and what i have observed was that you
actually like in hugging face everyone
is actually sort of a developer advocate
empowering the users of hugging face
like i attended this print and i have
learned a lot of things because people
were actually helping me out uh so
i felt like this is what i'm going to do
so that's why i applied for you know
developer advocacy
uh
we basically build tools and do
integrations it's mostly a technical job
by the way because developed advocacy
varies from
company to company
we do integrations uh we
we build content around them so that we
can democratize it currently i have this
project called a task
pages and task series
uh it is
it the audience of this project is
mostly the software developers because i
was a struggling machine learning
engineer previously
and i thought you know like if you want
to build a product the things that you
need to know are actually use cases
metrics you know a little bit of them
uh explain simply
um the models that you need to use the
data sets you have to find you know like
all of them
need to be like in one place as a task
in my opinion at least
so that's why the first time i arrived i
decided i'm going to do this because i
know that there are people like me out
there who are struggling to build
machine learning products
so
this is something i'm currently doing
this is more of a democratization effort
for software developers
um
yeah like my job consists of doing
integrations and this mostly and doing
um
doing
just getting out there and tell everyone
what we are doing actually i am doing a
talks on tensorflow and spaces like this
one
awesome
thank you there any more questions
yeah i'm good thanks a lot for for your
talks and for all the answers to the
questions
thank you so much for hosting me bye-bye